[Music]
if your teenager considering
entrepreneurship as a career and you're
asking how can I find a mentor to show
me the way
hang tight hang tight before he spent
thousands of dollars on these online
experts and gurus that are going to
change your life if you buy their
software and watch this 42 steps it's
completely going to revolutionize your
life
hang tight before you do that I'm
explained to why that is a few months
back I did a video titled fourteen ways
teenage entrepreneurs can make money
that on YouTube you got a few hundred
thousand views and forget about the
views it brought thousands of snapchat
messages that I had to respond to hey
Pat I'm 14 years old I want to be an
entrepreneur
I love value taming I just want to how
do I get started hip-hop I'm 16 years
old I'm thinking about starting business
what do I do hip out on 15 years I'm did
it got so many messages and finally I
said listen this one guy multiple Pat
I'm about to have my mother pay for this
guy he's named six thousand dollars and
he's going to help me become a
millionaire what do you think should I
do it or not I say yes my mom saying no
what do you think I said hang tight
because here's the thing you got to be
thinking about the first thing you've
got to think about if you want to become
an entrepreneur and get a mentor you
need to know what level you're at let me
explain what I mean by what level you're
at if you choose to become a bodybuilder
there's a personal trainer based out of
Venice Beach California okay he works at
Venice with you this is the gym of gym
this is like the Gold's Gym Arnold would
go workout back in the days I mean this
took place Franco Columbu you know
wieder would send us boys over there
this is the place to go to and Charles
Glass is like God to bodybuilders as a
per if he personally trains you you are
very lucky but he's two three four
hundred dollars an hour so what if you
send 14 years I'm thinking about lifting
weights do you need to go get Charles
Watson no you just need to get the
basics about weightlifting to see if
even sparks something in you just even
something catches and in all of a sudden
you fall in love with bodybuilding then
it's a whole different story forget
about it then you're eventually going to
get to his level so the question I want
you to ask yourself is what level of
entrepreneurship are you at right now
with the level of income think about
this year there's four tiers four tiers
tier number one you're watching this
you're 14 years old teenager thinking
about becoming an entrepreneur but this
is how much money you made as an
entrepreneur zero
dollars you don't know how to start you
can find somebody right now that's
making $3,000 a month as a teenage
entrepreneur that can be a mentor to you
now what if you're saying Pat I am
making $2,000 a month as a teenage
entrepreneur you know what do I do with
that then you need to find a level 2
tier 2 that's making 3 to 10 thousand
dollars a month and see what that person
can show you how to do what if example
Pat I'm making nine thousand dollars a
month they need a tier three hundred
thousand two million Pat I'm making
$300,000 per year then maybe you need a
tier for a million in up now watch this
what if you've never made money and
you're saying can this person show me
how to do things this person is going to
speak certain language to you're not
going to understand it's like going to a
new country trying to long Portuguese
you're not going to speak it so this
person is going to get frustrated and
you're going to get frustrated because
he's expecting you to speak his language
at this level and you don't even know
how to say book we got to first teach
you how to say book that's what you got
to learn and I know as a 14-year old you
want to become a billionaire by 15
because right now every single magazine
you watch it says what now the youngest
billionaire is 23 years old now the
youngest billionaire is 19 years old now
the youngest bit there is so much of
that going on that everybody's
forgetting the basic fundamentals going
back to I need to learn the basic steps
together so now having said this you
know what level you're in now let's go
over here let's go over here so what do
you look for when you're looking for a
mentor how do I find a mentor the
biggest recommendation I can Terry I
talked to tell you I talked about it
this in another video that I just want
to re remind you anytime you're choosing
a mentor you got to keep the T theory in
mind T theory what is the T theory when
it comes on to Mentors
t EA T Theory T is theory he is
experience a is application let me
explain there are mentors out there who
are very good at teaching you theories
but they've never done it it's called
University Professors okay it's called
college professors here's how you run a
business I'm sorry miss Jones have you
ever had a business before I haven't but
I've consulted many no have you ran a
business I have not but that's not the
point I've read all the books that's a
theory nothing wrong with it but their
theory there
lowest level of teachers to bring your
value they still can bring your value
but they're not the highest level then
you have experience you know with the
experience experiences somebody say have
you ever ran a business mr. Jones all
this stuff you write about in this book
I never ran a business but guess what I
work under Steve Jobs for six years
that's a lot of value that's experience
it what's a name but he watched somebody
who was doing it in the experience being
close to him have you ever done real
estate before I never have but who were
you I was the assistant for the number
one real estate agent in Beverly Hills
who sold 50 million dollars of homes per
year for ten years in row now that's
money right there
but that person's can tell you so what
time did it come in what time did he
leave what time did he do how did you do
it what did you do how would you how
would you treat his clients what would
tell me the biggest fight tell me
because I did was there time it was
almost going out of business that's the
experience and a level three highest one
is the actual source this is a person
that actually what they're telling you
they've done its work for them so this
is the entrepreneur who has their own
theories who has experience and who has
applied his theories his experience
that's gotten to where he's at I called
these guys trifectas you're looking for
trifectas as a mentor and by the way
they're tough to find they're tough to
find trifecta somebody like if you were
to say a mosque truck traffic the Cuban
trifecta you go to certain people who
are running businesses they're
traffickers there's a lot of online
YouTube videos who are purely level one
and level two they're now level three
now some of them because of the tens of
thousands of dollars people about to buy
their courses now they're investors and
they say I'm an investor by the way just
to call yourself an investor just so
everybody knows if I give Z here five
dollars to go buy gum at Walmart and
sell it for fifteen dollars I am an
investor f.y.i anybody can call
themselves it's so fascinating when
people call themselves investors anybody
can call themselves an investor I can
simply put money into mutual fund a
million dollars ten million dollars into
one of my mutual fund accounts and say I
have invested into 500 different fortune
500 companies it's called start a mutual
fund and an SMP account and put a
million dollars into it so again do some
due diligence on your own to know what
is a T theory and apply as much as you
can try as much as you can to get an
application tap of a
mentor that's trifecta and I haven't
said that so now how do we find the
mentors how do I get a mentor as a
teenage entrepreneur four levels number
one a dead mentor what is a dead mentor
Steve Jobs is dead
go studies content go study anybody that
worked with them go study anybody that
work closely to him go watch his
interviews go watch every one of his
interviews go see how he answers go see
how he thinks go see how his enemy said
what they said about him why did his
enemies not like and what did his enemy
say about and what did people in Silicon
Valley say about him go study
Rockefeller what happened to Rockefeller
what happened with Rockefeller and
Carnegie what were the fights about what
did rockefeller do is a dead mentor go
study Franklin Benjamin Franklin is
probably one of the least recognized
entrepreneurs to study go study how that
guy came up go study how we went to
Europe and negotiated deals go study his
battles with relatives go study Benjamin
Franklin dead mentor you know who can go
and be mentored by Benjamin Franklin
that 13 year old kid that's watching
right now from Nigeria that 14 year old
kid you that's watching it from Spain
you can go study Benjamin Franklin you
can go study Jobs you can go study
Rockefeller they're all dead dead
mentors I would much rather have you
studied those dead mentors then pay
$6,000 to an online guru that's going to
change your life I would much rather
have you study some dead mentors number
to an online mentor now what do I mean
by an online mentor I'm not talking all
I mentor you pay I'm talking online
mentor that has content accessible to
you do not spend money until you finally
learn how to do curls dumbbells basic
chest then you need to learn how to do
the cables because you want to work your
obliques then you want to learn how to
do shoulder presses that you Bend here
because you want to hit a certain spot
on your shoulders but at first just
learned how to do shoulder presses there
are many online mentors that can teach
you basics about marketing all this
other stuff matter of fact if you
haven't watched value tamer my challenge
to you would be this watch all the value
teaming videos and look what happens to
you it'll typically take you a couple
months to watch the whole thing
watch what happen you won't speak the
same language I have so many people
every day I get hundreds of messages
every single we got to say week every
weekend get hundreds of messages that
people say i watch this video i grew my
business from seven thousand dollars a
month to eighty three thousand dollars a
month i'm a teenage entrepreneur 13
years old today i made
$625 because of what was talked about in
the video 14 ways teenage entrepreneurs
make money online mentors they're out
there you can find them there's a lot of
content to study mix a local center rim
phone so for instance find out locally
if there's somebody that's running a
local business I don't know doing five
hundred thousand dollars your liquor
store somebody that's running a real
estate shop somebody that's running gay
whatever it is I remember when I was
coming up I called the guy and I told
him I said look I went and interviewed
him for a job he enter me for a job and
I chose not to work there but I was so
impressed by this guy's then was Jamie I
was so impressed by them I kept his
business card and I came back to him
three months later and I said look all I
asked you is just to allow me to take
you out to lunch once a quarter I don't
want anything from you I'll promise you
a few things I'm going to grow I'm going
to be successful I'm gonna win in life
I'm going to work my butt off and
eventually I'm going to become so
successful that I will bring value to
you in any way possibly because I'm
embedded to you and he saw the eyes
because eyes can't lie and eventually he
said you know what no prom took him up
on the deal we'd go to this restaurant
together on Venice I think was on Venice
and Santa Monica was called bamboo and
we'd have this great ref I think was
Argentinian food that was our spot we'd
go then he would see me bone and at one
time I was speaking at a high school
that I was invited to 600 kids were
there then he came then our relationship
grew told it from level then I spent my
birthday at his house we were together
talking all this stuff he said he's
doing very very well for himself but it
was a local center of influence and
that's where I got started when I was 21
years old that's why I got started when
I was 21 years old finding somebody
locally that's successful next shadow a
successful entrepreneur what shadowing a
successful entrepreneur if you can get
to this level by the way this doesn't
happen overnight but if you can get to
this level where you get in sometimes
you just got to get in you get in and
you got this one guy worth 100 million
bucks he's worth 200 million bucks he's
worth 300 million dollars and he's
locally he's working if you can be
around that environment and you see the
most important thing to learn is
conflict that's what you want to learn
you want to learn conflicts you want to
learn negotiations you want to learn the
fight you want to learn the enemies you
want to learn how do we
into this enemy you want to learn those
types of things you want to be in the
meeting and just listen to how dialogues
are being done you want to study their
mannerisms you want to know how their
brain is wired you want to know how they
process certain issues you want to stay
late and if their day to get a 10-minute
conversation that's what you're looking
for when you're able to work with a
successful entrepreneur you can shadow
for a few minutes when I had a chance to
do this I didn't care what time it was
I'm there because I just want to run all
I'm looking for is feet my mind I just
want to see things I can do better how
is this guy doing certain things that I
can pick up for myself so with that
being said teenagers with the aspiration
of becoming an entrepreneur which I can
tell you here it's one of the craziest
decisions you'll make but if you're
serious and you got it in your blood to
become an entrepreneur and you're
willing to improve and learn you do your
part that's one of the best decisions
you'll ever make the options you have to
do a quick recap what tier are you where
are you at and make sure you're always
going to tier ahead to learn from them
because you speak the same language if
not a little bit more than you find the
key theory trifecta entrepreneurs and I
find out which one of these four mentors
you can go out and learn from and it
would that being said if you got any
questions about that we can snap me but
don't snap and say Pat can you mentor me
because I get that every day don't snap
and tell me mentor me if you haven't
watched all the value 10 videos first
things first you got to watch all the
value teaming videos and the way I know
is if you comment on every single one of
them that you watch I watch this here's
what I've got I watch this here's what
I've got because I will test you so
first things first you got any questions
you can snap me on snap tape you see the
image over here spit David 19 if you got
any questions or thoughts comment on the
bottom
do not spend that money before you
follow this system if you got friends
that are about to spend that money on an
online mentor this $6,000 5 that
whatever the numbers share this video
with them and if you have not subscribed
to the number one how to channel for
entrepreneurs on YouTube please do so
and YouTube's got this new thing here I
keep telling everybody about click right
next to it it's an alert button what
happens is you become one the first to
be notified every time a new value Tim
in episode goes up on YouTube so please
subscribe our goal is to get 2 million
subs before 2017 just a year ago we read
5000 subs or so right
we're at 155 thousand subs and our plan
is a year from now
December 31st 2017 to crack 1 million
subs on YouTube and we need your help to
get us 2 million subs there we go then
it's good catch again comment on the
bottom of questions and thoughts thanks
for watching everybody take care
you